♪ ♪
>> Bill: AN ALERT NOW THAN
COVID-19 PANDEMIC SENT DEPLOYED
AIRPORT CARE IS BACK TO PORT
AFTER TWO DOZEN CREWMEMBERS
TESTED POSITIVE.
THE U.S. THEODORE ROOSEVELT
MONITORING CHINA FROM THE SOUTH
CHINA SEA.
MEANWHILE, THE PENTAGON REPORTS
COVID-19 CASES IN THE U.S.
MILITARY HAVE QUADRUPLED IN LESS
THAN A WEEK WITH 280 280 SERVICE
MEMBERS INFECTED.
JENNIFER GRIFFIN HAS THAT STORY
AND SHE REPORTS LIGHT FROM THE
PENTAGON WITH MORE ON THIS,
JENNIFER.
>> BILL THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED.
THE U.S. NAVY ONLY HAS THREE
DEPLOYED AIRCRAFT CARRIERS AT
SEA RIGHT NOW.
ONLY TODAY, WE LEARNED ONE OF
THEM HAS AN OUTBREAK OF
CORONAVIRUS FORCING IT TO A HALT
OPERATION AND HEAD INTO PORT IN
THE PACIFIC.
THE ACTING NAVY SECRETARY THOMAS
MOBLEY TOLD REPORTERS THURSDAY
MORNING THE U.S.
THEODORE ROOSEVELT WOULD BE
HEADING INTO PORT IN GUAMS
SOON AS POSSIBLE IN ORDER FOR
ALL 5,000 SAILORS AND PILOTS ON
BOARD TO BE TESTED FOR
CORONAVIRUS.
AMONG THE FIRST TO REPORT THAT
24 SAILORS ON BOARD THE
MASSIVE WORSHIP HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE AND TRIPLE THE NUMBER
FROM TWO DAYS AGO.
>> I KNOW THE SMALL SHIPS DON’T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO TEST ON
BOARD.
BUT IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING ON
THE LARGER SHIPS, WE DO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THE TESTING ON
BOARD.
>> LIMITED TO, SO ARE YOU SHORT
OF TEST SWABS ON BOARD SOMETHING
LIKE THAT TR ROOSEVELT?
>> TR HAS APPROXIMATELY 800 KIDS
ON BOARD AND WE ARE FLYING MORE
ON BOARD AS WE SPEAK SO WE WILL
HAVE MORE TO HELP SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
>> THE ROOSEVELT HAD PORT CALL
IN VIETNAM OVER TWO WEEKS AGO IN
RECENT WEEKS, ROOSEVELT FLYING
AROUND THE CLOCK AIR OPERATIONS
IN THE SOUTH CHINA SEA TO SEND A
MESSAGE TO BEIJING.
WITH THE CARRIER IMPORTANT GUAM,
THOSE FLIGHT OPTIONS WILL STOP
HERE THREE DAYS AGO, THE THREE
SAILORS TESTED POSITIVE PEER
THEY WERE FLOWN OFF OF THE SHIP.
THEN THERE WERE FIVE MORE AND
NOW WE LEARN TODAY 24 MORE
QUARANTINED.
THE SHIPS LIKE THE ROOSEVELT HAD
TO FLY THOSE TEST TO LAND BASES
WHICH DELAYED GETTING RESULTS.
IT IS THE FIRST TIME THE
CORONAVIRUS HAS AFFECTED A
WARSHIP AT C OF THIS SIZE.
CRITICS FEAR THE CARRIER COULD
BE THE NEXT PRINCESS CRUISE
LINER.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO PROTECT
SAILORS AT SEA GIVEN THE TIGHT
QUARTERS, BUILD.
>> Bill: THANK YOU JENNIFER
WE’VE BEEN DOWN THAT ROAD AND
U.S. NAVY HOSPITAL SHIPS
EXPECTED TO ARRIVE SOON IN
LOS ANGELES AND MAYBE NEXT WEEK
IN NEW YORK CITY.
>> THAT IS RIGHT, BILL.
WE LEARNED THE U.S. MERCY WILL
BE IMPORTANT IN LOS ANGELES ON
FRIDAY.
AND READY TO TAKE NONCORONAVIRUS
PATIENTS WITHIN 24 HOURS OF
DOCKING.
IT HAS ABOUT 1,000 BEDS ON
BOARD, AND THE HOSPITAL SHIP
COMFORT WILL PUT THIS WEEKEND
AND HEAD TO NEW YORK EARLY AND
SHOULD BE THERE AS EARLY THIS